[Music]
hi-tec Gallagher with recent TV the
Slamdance Film Festival in Park City
Utah the name of the film is graphic
sexual horror my name is Barbara Bell
I'm one of the directors and producers a
mother and son I'm also a director and
producer and I'm Lorelei Lee I'm a cast
member in the film I was a model for
insects calm which was a hardcore
bondage website and I worked there for
about two years one thing we would do is
live feed shoots where we would have
extended bondage and s/m scenes in which
I would probably be you know tied in
different positions and do different
kinds of either like domination and
Submission games or s/m games with more
corporal punishment with things like
canes or whipped or other implements
east electricity what they did was the
the Homeland Security Department sent a
letter to the banks telling them that
violent porn web sites were known to
funnel money to terrorists and if you
know anything about the Patriot Act this
then gives them a right if they believe
the bank is working with such websites
to look into their books and look into
their their business which of course
they don't want so they would then deny
primary merchant accounts to these
websites and if you don't have the
ability to process credit cards you
basically don't have a business if
you're if you're on the web and so it's
just a matter of shutting down the
website you were
yes
not that kind of terrorism that they
were trying to get rid of no there's
also the very interesting gag order
which basically means that you could be
thrown in jail for talking about
something that's being done through the
Patriot Act yeah yeah it could but I
hope that this new administration won't
do anything that they're gonna get rid
of this somehow but it was it was pretty
daring for the bank employee to actually
show PD the owner of the website the
letter that came from the Homeland
Security Department because he was
putting himself at risk doing that but I
mean they they were a pretty big
customer and they showed that this is
why they had to cancel the account
there was nothing brought against him
personally it was all backdoor way of
shutting off his revenue stream and once
his revenue stream was shut down he was
forced to shut down the website and
actually I have to say that they did the
same thing with some gambling online
gambling websites at the same time so
they're getting more and more sneaky
about how they want to do this obscenity
or porn cases because it's very hard to
get an obscenity court case through the
court system I know they succeeded with
max hardcore but they've been trying
many other ones and didn't succeed many
websites I'm sure were put under the
same types of pressure that he was and
the other thing that he says is that you
know websites that we're making a lot
more money than him had the ability to
pressure the bank back the other way
I think they have so many problems left
over from the last administration that
they're gonna be really busy dealing
with issues of torture
you know surveillance with you know
without a warrant financial meltdown I
think that there are a lot more serious
things to worry about the porn
[Music]